I was the 11th child of my dad's 45. we
weren't half siblings we were siblings
my brother that was two months older
than me was my brother
it's not from the same mom but that
didn't matter
99 of the people that I knew had the
last name Wayman my same last name
I have one dad four moms and 44 siblings
oh
I definitely know all of them by name
Aaron Leroy Pamela clean guy Mary
Miranda Michelle Melanie David Calvin
that's me Anna Jonathan Joshua yes I
could go down the whole list we just
have a WhatsApp group that we call
siblings
[Music]
everything is only obviously a cult
when it's looked at in totality that
like becomes your normal because it's
all I knew
there are so many things
around this
that don't add up but if I'm being
honest
as good as it is
it just doesn't feel
right
we all grew up in the same house
we also grew up on a farm we often
worked together growing the corn
Tomatoes we also had animals we had
these things called the garments there's
jokes about this on the outside world
known as a Jesus jammies
your garments are super special because
they're like a protector every girl was
supposed to wear a dress all the guys
wear long sleeves never shorts of course
some families were against sandals
[Music]
the specific little church that I was in
I think they estimate 2 000 the whole
flds Church movement I think is
estimated around 60 000 members
[Music]
we would like have family prayer right
before bed sometimes and then we would
tell
especially my dad good night not always
all the other moms but because in flds
culture it's very patriarchal
having five parents in some ways I think
that creates more opportunity for love I
think a lot of teenagers start to have
friction with their biological parents
and I actually got closer to one of my
other moms
to be fair there were there were some
definite parts of childhood that were
not good
I almost never went in public if a car
was coming down the street we were
taught to hide behind a bush or get in
the house so people couldn't see us they
were psychological punishments that God
is going to be mad at you
and
I experienced physical punishment many
times
beatings
getting punched
getting kicked in different situations
whipped with a belt
one time my cousin Richard and I time
got away from us I think it was like 10
30 and we were still sitting in his
driveway talking one of his moms comes
out and then she sees us and she's like
your dad's looking for you you better
get your butt back home so I sped back
home and again because I was out 30
minutes past curfew
I was taken into the barn and I was
physically punished even though it
purported to be a Christian faith there
wasn't a lot of forgiveness for certain
sins
the flds church is still racist for
example like if you're African-American
you could not hold a a leadership
position in the church
if you leave the church
that's showing that you turned against
it so leaving is not just leaving if you
leave and if you're wrong you're Damned
to hell you burn in eternity like I
didn't feel safe in my own thoughts
[Music]
I had a deep curiosity around learning
so I wanted to keep learning so I went
to my dad and I said I want to go to
college
I picked a class called philosophy man
that class is what created what I call
the crack
and I realized in that moment there
wasn't anything almost nothing that was
really meaningful
that I had internally discovered
I studied it for years and I started to
have even more questions and it didn't
get better
I knew it was significant
because I knew something major was about
to shift
I had tremendous pain and anger
realizing
what I was in and realizing the things
about it that were so incredibly toxic
and destructive what I'm about to say I
think is the first time I've ever really
recorded myself saying this out loud is
whether or not I am going to stay
with
the community
I don't think I am going to stay
I eventually left the community in the
middle of covid then I made a video on
Facebook some people
they took it very personally
and so I was attacked on social media
because I would dare leave the one thing
that was most dear to me
I ended up in an arranged marriage
that it was a church arranged marriage
like shortly after leaving the religion
my ex became my ex because she wanted to
stay I didn't want to stay
I wanted to live a life that felt true
to who I was
even if
I was going to be damned
[Music]
when I was really young I had a really
close spot with my dad
you know just like
any
young boy I mean you look up and your
dad is Superman I found out last year
that my dad is dying he has stage four
prostate cancer
we got to talk
and he said something that I had never
thought I would ever hear in my life
and he said sorry
I got to express
my forgiveness I got to express the
appreciation of the good times
it's been a process from that day till
now and even the last few years has been
a process since leaving because I feel
like in some ways I didn't have a parent
even though it looked like I had five
the adjustment's been
an exciting Adventure I love putting
myself in new situations like I've
traveled a lot and I love it
I grew up in a small town but New York
City is where where I think my next big
chapter is with putting my roots down
I'm still
learning still want to show love even
those that come from where I come from
even though I'm 35 years old I'm a baby
in this new life
one life so all I'm saying is if you
really realize you only got one
what is it that you really want to do
what's the life you really want to live
live it that way
[Music]
my parents would ties together via a
rope so that we were always together and
I could always thank her she obeyed the
therapist when she heard that story was
just
like really shocked and she looked at me
and she said Elizabeth that's child
abuse